[Música]
en la edad de tx mondoñedo özil yo te
olvida
como veis hemos pasado en el audio
latino al chino en muy poco tiempo
vivimos en un mundo intercultural
cuántos de vosotros habláis chino
poca mano se ve por ahí bueno ya sabéis
una palabra que se compone de peligro y
oportunidad
[Música]
hoy os vengo a contar una historia como
podéis ver aquí no soy yo en carnavales
o halloween sino es mi padre que vino de
pekín a madrid en el año 1983 a
emprender
la palabra emprender está tan de moda
pero hace 35 años la gente no se atrevía
el vio más oportunidad
qué peligro y se vino sin saber nada de
inglés sin saber nada de castellano y
con 20 dólares en los bolsillos eso es
emprender cuántos de vosotros os
dejaríais todo ahora mismo para irse a
china a emprender
ahora sí que veo más manos se nota que
estamos en galicia
muy bien pues esta es la historia de mi
padre pero simplemente os quiero
comentar unos puntos que él tuvo que
pasar después de muchos fracasos pudo
ahorrar dinero y comprar el típico
restaurante chino en la costa levantina
y mi madre y yo nos venimos en en el año
1990 yo con 10 años
pues él tuvo que trabajar muchísimo yo
creo que la expresión de trabajar como
un chino se inspiraron en él y menos mal
que eso no se hereda menos mal otra cosa
si el físico como podéis ver sí que se
hereda
pero él tuvo muchísimo momento de
flaqueza y yo le preguntaba después de
mucho tiempo no tengo papá porque no te
coge este todas tus cosas y volviste a
china y dice porque existe un concepto
en la cultura china que es el mienta que
es el rostro tu dignidad por dicción
alguna forma si tú ha sido extranjero a
triunfar a emprender y vuelves sin tener
nada eso socialmente está muy mal visto
y la entendí
y claro durante mucho tiempo mi padre no
tenía trabajo y tuvo que construir su
propia red de contactos que es este
concepto que es el cual en sí pero ahí
tuvo dos problemas primero hace 35 años
la comunidad china no era tan extensa
como ahora se encontraron con gente de
taiwán que no quería saber nada de la
gente de china continental por problemas
políticos y también había gente del sur
que tampoco se entendía del todo con mi
padre por problemas lingüísticos por lo
tanto poco a poco tuvo que construir su
propia red de contacto ex el cuentico
para estar posicionados de entrada de
comunidad china para que unos y otros
ayudarán para tener un negocio parte de
una vida mejor
y bien pues después de mucho tiempo en
el año 1990 llegamos lo que llamamos la
segunda generación
que somos chicos que hemos crecido o
hemos nacido en españa que tenemos lo
mejor y lo peor de las dos culturas de
hecho nos llamamos chino les ni chinos
ni españoles si no les lo que
técnicamente se llama una cerca al ser
que un chico de tercera cultura nosotros
aquí nos ponemos nuestra máscara hispana
y somos chino les la palma acuñada por
un chino gallego yo me considero un
chino
de levante-valencia no hay señores
catalanes y sobre todo hay señores
andaluces que ofrece a la hora de hablar
y cierran los ojos dice no puede ser que
estoy hablando con chino
y claro yo sería un ejemplo de ello yo
vengo con 10 años estudios y renunciar
mis propias raíces chinas
sigo manteniendo el idioma sigo teniendo
amigos pero mi pareja es española por lo
tanto la siguiente generación nuestros
hijos por decir una forma sin secuenciar
el adn lo llamarán chinos también serán
más chillones todavía y el otro extremo
estaría el caso de mi amiga susana y que
es periodista y es directora de un
documental que se llama bananas y si no
les señores ya sabemos lo que es bananas
para que os hagáis una idea somos chinos
que tengo en la piel amarilla por fuera
pero somos muy blancos por dentro ahora
mismo ella está en china ella no sabe
chino sus padres son del sur tampoco le
enseñará un dialecto tiene pasaporte
chino pero nació aquí en españa por lo
tanto estoy esperando que vuelva a china
para que me cuenten sus anécdotas como
pasaría en la frontera es decir la
policía esperándole
está esperándola y ella se hablará de
chino intentar cruzar
pasaporte chino a ver si en presente de
aquí podemos contar esta experiencia
bueno para resumir tanto la generación
de mis padres como nuestra generación
tenemos muchas cosas en común a pesar de
nuestra diferencia nuestra diversidad
compartimos unos valores unas creencias
y unos comportamientos fuertemente
arraigados en la cultura china
y hay que conocer ciertas pautas y
claves culturales como el cual mientras
que hemos visto para poder comunicar de
forma óptima
tanto con los chinos como con los chinos
es muchas gracias
[Aplausos]